well Michael I was just talking
obviously about how the movie really
feels like it could be from the 80s and
I I almost feel like there's there's a
level that you can cross where you sort
of could or could not choose to have
some details in yeah I mean that was the
challenge in the term I used with
hindsight humour and I didn't want to
have any hindsight humor so the goal you
think whatever you think about the movie
but our goal is making it in writing was
to have Taffet be told from the
first-person perspective of a
thirteen-year-old in present day 1985
who did not even know what the word
irony meant or you know it's a earnest
to the point of embarrassment maybe you
guys as first-time actors how was it for
you jumping in miles this is your very
first film correct your first feature it
was really chill onset like it was like
no pressure at all so just like go ahead
and do it alright cool I mean I wasn't
bad at all
marchello how about you I mean the whole
acting thing was just like a whole new
experience like our first day was just
like I see an ice cream and like playing
games and stuff so I mean it was kind of
easy to like work into and then we
started getting into the harder stuff
but Michael was always there for us
helping us out giving us advice and he
just really brought us all together and
made it work yeah I really think that
the whole atmosphere on set was just a
lot of support at all times and I mean
you can tell by the film that it's a fun
storyline and the atmosphere on set was
just a lot of energy and really fun so I
thought as far as a first act real
feature film acting experience it was
the best um I feel for read it was kind
of just like a little bit of awkwardness
and him just trying to like find himself
and just see who he really is
and when he goes the Ocean City on
vacation he kind of figures out who he
is and he meets miles and he meets Emmy
and all them and it's just him finding
himself really how I would explain it
that's going on in your face and your
eyes during during a lot of those those
scenes is really nice nice remember the
when he was doing the beach scene the
mist kiss and that was the last night we
shot actually and Wyatt the
cinematographer and I really
like what is he doing it's like this is
some like Woody Allen performance of
like his eyeballs are sort of creating
and I was like I'm not directing anymore
he's just he's rolling with it you know
but it is really difficult like you said
and then maybe miles what about
I mean Teddy he was just trying to like
he was kind of like a loner at first and
then he found rad and he was like wow
this is awesome
I mean he really just needed someone to
like stick to you because you really
have any friends and then he was like
really opened up and was a goofy kid I I
think that Stacy's a really interesting
character because she kind of fluctuates
between protagonists and antagonists
like I mean she's obviously not the
protagonist but you know what I mean I
just think that there had to be such a
balance between good and bad for her
throughout the whole film and I think
that's what made her a very dynamic love
interest character not just the cut and
paste pretty blonde girl that he has a
crush on cinema to graphically the movie
really has got a great feel to it it
does have that for a grainy feel from
like in 1982 or 83 and although
stop-motion moments those kind of stop
and zoom in moments that we're in a lot
of 80s movies are kind of more than you
sort of are aware of their sort of
lodged in the back of my mind a little
even I would say even Logitech Chris
Marker if we want to get real film dirty
and then they're like dolly of the
buffet was a minute long dolly of the
buffet I was like let's go Bella Tarr
here let's go to Hungary for this shot
but yeah with with we had the discussion
and now I feel like even in the past
year used to have the discussion are we
shooting film are we shooting digital
and it's just so discouraging to me and
depressing a little bit is that it's
just so quickly everyone's moved past it
and digital is doing great things but if
you're trying to make I quickly on a
phone call said to the producers I would
be insecure presenting this movie to an
audience that was supposed to be made in
1985 if we didn't shoot on film and
everyone just right away I was like
that's the discussion now the difference
is we shot on super 16 millimeter versus
35 and I think if we'd shot on 35 the
budget would have been exponentially
increased but I prefer the the grid and
grain a big production model I don't
know if anyone knows the movie This Is
England chain Meadows for
late a mid-2000s I think that was a real
big production model to say this feels
like I made for BBC drama from the 80s
and although our movie was inspired by
Hollywood movies it was still that that
precedence there's a great moment with
with Amy Sedaris when she is showing her
tan line and you sort of give the wide I
think and it and it reminded me of what
a what a great beautiful scene stealer
you are very quietly being able to steal
a scene there is Amy Sedaris who there
and then with one look it all shifts
back to you well you know she was a
woman of a few words I think in our
conversation when I decided to do the
movie I was like oh she may be say some
more and you were like no I don't think
so and I was like all right I'll do the
movie watch but yeah I just thought the
characters were really funny I hadn't
done one like that kind of big of a
character for a while and it was
actually based on your mom right
he had me listen to her talk do my lines
in the strange accent and one from
Maryland here's to understand the
Maryland accent it's very hard to beat
ah I didn't pull it off so I went with
the site I decided she was from Virginia
somewhere and gave her a southern accent
because I just didn't wasn't paid enough
to learn boys coach go boys coach for
this there was not in the budget I would
have needed a voice coach maybe for a
week I might have gotten it but it's
just such a crazy dialect and it changes
block-to-block because she was raised
there but she doesn't have the the same
accent thing that I needed to me has
been pointed out like when I was younger
I'd have it pointed out a little bit but
as I've gotten older I don't I don't
want to have it you know I don't want to
like doing I think it's up I don't want
to have this round
Oh sneaking in all the time and there's
crazy words out of nowhere you're like
wow hey I also saw saw your character in
some ways like she could easily have
been sort of the mom of like your
character in all the right moves or
something I think if you kind of like
had that sense of like you know she or
she could have been that obvious in that
character you know 25 years later like
she kind of recognized in her son a
certain rebellious Ness that she
probably recognized
our youth was that something that you
thought about yeah I did and I I I felt
like you know cuz I've been playing moms
in the 80s for 30 years now so I'm you
jerk that's right qualified to play this
part but you know what you know people
always go what does it like to play a
mom and I you know moms are just women
you know they're just they have
different things and you know I just
they're different they're just people
with babies I think that that she was a
really unique character and he gave me a
lot of little clues you know just the
fact that she was so cheap and that she
was just trying to keep her family
together and that she was trying to you
know just do the best she could and it
and she really is a good mom she she
really is and they it was a really nice
family and that's what you're saying it
wasn't this functional it was just what
quirky like every family